fans have been desperate for a follow-up
to Quentin Tarantino's seminal film Pulp
Fiction since it hit the Silver Screen
but 30 years later it seems unlikely
that we'll ever see a sequel Pulp
Fiction was the second feature film made
by writer director Quentin Tarantino
he's now closing in on his 10th and in
2023 he celebrated his 60th birthday
sadly Tarantino has often talked up the
notion of retiring after both of those
Milestones unfortunately for Die Hard
Pulp Fiction fans that 10th film isn't
going to be a follow-up to the 1994
Classic instead it's a project called
the movie critic which is about a 1970s
critic who reviews films for a porno
magazine if it really is his final film
that kills off quite a few potential
Tarantino projects at various points in
his career he's floated ideas Like a
gangster-style Star Trek movie a third
Kill Bill entry and a movie about black
soldiers during World War II so assuming
that Tarantino sticks to his guns when
it comes to feature film retirement we
won't be seeing any of those movies play
out on the big screen in other words the
time has passed for Pulp Fiction too
other persistent issues have long dogged
Pulp Fiction to ownership and rights as
it turns out it may have been tough for
Tarantino to even legally make a sequel
to his own film the director owns the
copyright of the Pulp Fiction script but
Miramax owns the finished film evidently
when Tarantino tried to make Pulp
Fiction nfts he wound up in a lawsuit
with Miramax that ended in 2022 if just
making non-fungible tokens was that
contentious imagine how it might have
hampered the making of another movie
over the last three decades Pulp Fiction
writer director Quentin Tarantino has
openly discussed at least three films
that would have expanded the film's
universe in the 1990s following the
back-to-back successes of Reservoir Dogs
and Pulp Fiction Tarantino toyed with
the idea of linking the two films in a
new project called double v Vega in that
movie Michael Madsen and John Travolta
would have reprized their respective
Reservoir Dogs and Pulp Fiction roles of
Vic Vega and Vincent Vega because
they're Brothers essentially a prequel
to both movies it would have been about
the Vegas siblings hanging out in
Amsterdam a trip that Vincent Vega
alludes to in his Pulp Fiction opening
monologue Tarantino never went anywhere
with double v Vega which was also billed
as the Vega Brothers other than that
premise and given that 30 years have
passed it's probably too late for Madsen
and Travolta to play younger versions of
their characters as for other
possibilities there's a scene in Pulp
Fiction in which Jules Winfield tells
Vincent I'm just gonna walk the earth
what you mean walk to Earth you know
like Cain and Kung Fu walk from place to
place meet people getting Adventures
Tarantino thought about making that
single line of dialogue into a whole
movie but he told movie nerds that it
never moved beyond the idea realm as for
the third potential film while promoting
Kill Bill in 2003 Tarantino told otiaroa
news that a sequel was stirring he said
there's an idea I have bottom line the
studio wants it fans want it I'm sure I
can compromise somewhere it'd be my way
of apologizing for never getting Vega
Brothers off the ground I guess
nevertheless that movie never did get
produced due to the events of the first
Pulp Fiction and circumstances affecting
the cast's ability or willingness to
participate in the present day any
follow-up film set in the same Cinematic
Universe couldn't serve as a direct
sequel for example Vincent Vega
portrayed by John Travolta in the film
doesn't make it out of Pulp fictional
Live While Bruce Willis who played Rogue
boxer Butch Coolidge retired from acting
after developing dementia as for the
rest of the cast it seems like it might
take Tarantino a lot of work to convince
Samuel L Jackson to reprise his role of
Hitman Jules Winfield in 2022 Tarantino
derisively discussed the marvelization
of Hollywood on the podcast two bears
one cave Jackson portrays Nick Fury
throughout the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and took on bridge at his Pulp Fiction
director's comments firing back at him
on The View as for Uma Thurman who
played Mia Wallace her relationship with
Tarantino has been Rocky in 2018 she
told the New York Times that she nearly
died in a car stunt gone awry during the
filming of killed Bill a stunt the
director reportedly forced her to do and
allegedly Tarantino spat on her and
choked her for two separate scenes
Thurman has said that she forgave
Tarantino for the car incident after the
director apologized and it's very likely
the filmmaker could patch things up with
Jackson over their Marvel Feud still it
seems like there might be some friction
between Tarantino and the key players
involved so even if a Pulp Fiction 2
were a possibility getting the band back
together might be pretty difficult at
this point
writing directing producing and
releasing a movie particularly a sequel
to a 30 year old film is a difficult and
complicated task it might be more
pragmatic and easier for Tarantino to
release the long rumored and often
speculated Pulp Fiction follow-up in
another format like the written word a
medium Tarantino is actively explored in
recent years in 2021 he published Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood a novelization
an expansion of his 2019 film of the
same name and according to Dave Poland
in the 2010s Tarantino began writing a
literary spin-off of his Django
Unchained project called Django and
white hell which evolved into the
hateful eight however he did give Django
life on the page hearing the gunfighting
hero up with one of the world's most
famous masked vigilantes in the comic
book Django Zorro and while these aren't
real sequels other artists and
professionals have Revisited the world
of Pulp Fiction in their projects in
2023 deadline reported that production
had started on stealing pulp addiction a
heist movie from director writer Danny
turkovitz about a group of friends who
try to abscond with Tarantino's copy of
the original 35 millimeter Pulp Fiction
film reels and back in 2014 Harvey
Keitel reprized his role as the
inscrutable and effective Pulp Fiction
fixer Winston wolf in a series of
commercials for UK insurance company
direct line